il est vrai que la raison beaucoup
souffert dans les dernières années elle
a été notamment la science qui a été
mise au rang des accusés par donald
trump mais il n'est pas le seul qu'on
pense par exemple aux polémique en
france sur les vaccins qui paraît
aujourd'hui bien dérisoire alors que
tout le monde aujourd'hui cherchent à
mettre au point un vaccin contre le
corona virus donc cette crise elle peut
comme toute crise est retourné à la
tragédie ou peut être un facteur de
chance elle peut accélérer la
décomposition des libertés publiques la
poussée populiste et donnait l'avantagé
aux démocrates eurent ou plan
international contre les démocraties où
venant après quand même une série
terrible de choc d'avertissement le 11
septembre les guerres perdues en
afghanistan en irak et en syrie
venant après le krach de 2008 qui a
montré une gestion complètement
irresponsable du capitalisme venant
après la crise de l'euro venant après
les les vagues migratoires
ce peut être un réveil pour les
démocraties occidentales et finalement
l'occasion pour elle de réaliser que
maintenant il faut vraiment qu'elle
serait avant tout qu'elle essaie de
travailler un nouveau pacte économique
et social qu'elle réponde le capitalisme
qu'elle renforce qu'elle réinvente une
communauté en des citoyens avec des
valeurs collectives plus forte et
qu'elle renoue justement avec la raison
et avec la liberté
[Musique]